- Hi, good afternoon, everyone.
I'm absolutely delighted to invite you all
to our monthly convening of the
Inference Colloquium Series.
Today, we have an exciting talk
from one of the core members
of our interdisciplinary
team, Dr. Jenann Ismael,
who is a preeminent Philosopher of Science
and on the Faculty at Columbia University.
But before I introduce her, more formally,
I would first like to thank
Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke
for the generosity and support
of Yale's flagship
Interdisciplinary Program,
the Frankie Program in
Science and the Humanities,
and many other activities at Yale.
I think they were planning
to join us here today.
So welcome.
I would like to remind you all
that as we are recording this event
and that for all participants
must mute their videos.
If you wish, please go ahead
and submit your questions
through the chat feature.
Per custom, Dr. Ty Kamp and I
will be monitoring the chat
and we'll read out the
questions after the talk
in the Q and A session.
So on to our speaker today.
Professor Jenann Ismael
joined the faculty at
Columbia University in 2018.
And most of her research work falls into
sort of two sort of classes,
two big sets of questions.
The first is sort of describes
the Central Concerns of
Philosophy of Physics.
And in that realm,
her interests include the
Structure of Space and Time.
The Foundations of Quantum Mechanics,
The Role of Simplicity
and Symmetry in Physics.
Questions about the nature of probability,
natural laws and causal relations.
So as you can see all
rather big and important,
very significant foundational questions.
And the second set of interests include,
A Mind Cognition Phenomenology,
and the Nature of
Perspectives.
Jenann received her PhD
from Princeton University
was a Mellon Fellow at
Stanford after that,
and then taught at the
university of Arizona
before coming to Columbia.
She is the recipient of
many honors and awards.
And I would just mention a few.
She has had several
prestigious Fellowships,
including an NEH Fellowship
at the National Humanities Center,
Queen Elizabeth the
second Research Fellowship
from the Australian Research
Council and Fellowships
and from the Templeton Foundation
and the Center for Advanced Studies
and Behavioral Science at Stanford.
And I'm also delighted to let you all know
that her conversing that the
discussion session tomorrow,
which will start at the same time
is Professor Jim Woodward,
who is a distinguished Professor
in the Department of History
and Philosophy of Science
at the University of Pittsburgh.
And I will tell you
more about him tomorrow
and before turning over
the floor to Jenann,
I would like to remind you
of some of our ongoing
and forthcoming projects
at the Frankie program.
I would particularly like to mention
the learning by doing project,
which is a collection of simple videos
for children to teach
them how science works
and the set of upcoming
inference project talks.
So our next inference project
talk will be in October
by Brian Cantwell Smith.
And meanwhile, with the Frankie Program,
we have a distinguished
speaker series talks
by Jordan Ellenberg in
early October, October six,
and by Hazel Carby November 3rd.
So anyway, without further ado,
once again, a warm welcome
to you all and to you Jenann
and to Jim, Jenann, the floor is yours.
- Thanks so much for having me
and special thanks to Jim Woodward
for agreeing to be the
conversant tomorrow.
So let me just,
so there's been kind of
enormous burgeoning of interest
in causation across the sciences
and the details of various
kinds of easy to locate.
So when can open up a
journal in microbiology
and be assailed with detailed models
of the causal structure
of cells and proteins.
One can textbooks on the
increasing array of computational
tools for causal search and discovery
and take classes devoted to,
for example, formal methods
and causal modeling.
Psychologists are unraveling new details
about how people use causal
concepts and reasoning
and will details of these
kinds are in abundant supply.
It's not easy to find among them
and answer to the question
of what causation is
or how it fits into
a physics-based ontology.
So I'm gonna try to fill that hole
by assembling the pieces
of our understanding,
emerging scientific
understanding causation
into an account of where
and how causation arises
in the architecture of the physical world
with special attention to
the contested questions
of where the direction
of causation comes from
it's connection to the
second law of thermodynamics
and the relationship between
causation and agency.
So if you've been attending
other talks in the series,
you'll have heard about
some of these things.
What I say will have the most in common
with Carlo Rovelli's beautiful talk
which opened the series,
with maybe a little more focused attention
on the philosophical questions.
So this will sort of bring
things background full circle.
I'm gonna adopt a very
high level perspective,
kind of pulling our gaze away from details
to try to pull the big pieces into place,
to get an overall view of the whole Vista.
So if one looks back at the
early history of science,
it can be seen as developing
out of systematization
and abstraction of causal thinking.
The search for an understanding
of the causal relations
among events that is as true physics
as it is at the other sciences.
So I think it's not wrong
to say as Russell Bertrand,
Russell did in 1955,
that the aim of physics
consciously or unconsciously
has always been to
discover what we may call
the causal skeleton of the world.
Now at first,
the notion of cause retained
its close connection
with mechanical ideas.
So a cause was something
that brought about its effect
by a transfer of force.
But by the time Newton
had finished with it,
causation didn't appear
in the final presentation
of his own theory at all.
What he put in the place
of causal relations
are mathematical equations, oops sorry.
Mathematical equations,
usually express in the form
of differential equations,
like give the rate of change
of a quantity over time.
Causes and the associated idea of force
dropped out of the final
presentation entirely.
There's no direction
and there's no asymmetry
of determination.
Later events determined earlier ones
as surely as earlier ones,
determined later ones.
And it's clear from the quote
that I just said about earlier
from Russell,
that Russell actually came around
to thinking quite differently.
But 32 years earlier,
he wrote in a paper on the notion of cause
that's the starting point of all,
almost every discussion
of causation and physics.
Now in that paper,
Russell noted that the kinds of laws
that Newtonian mechanic gives us
are so different from causal relations
as traditionally conceived.
Thus misleading to think of
them in causal terms at all.
And he urged that, sorry,
I keep doing this, sorry.
He urged that causation is a
folk notion that has no place
in immature science,
the modern discussion of causation
and the philosophy of science really began
after Russell with Cartwright's
deeply influential critique
of Russell's paper.
And what Cartwright pointed
out was that dynamic laws
cant play the role of
causal relations in science
because specifically causal
information is needed
to distinguish effective
from ineffective strategies
for bringing about ends.
So for example,
it might be true as a matter of law
because smoking causes bad breath,
but there's a strong, positive correlation
between bad breath and cancer.
But it is not true that
bad breath causes cancer.
And hence it's not true
that treating bad breath
is my effective strategy
for preventing cancer.
And that difference,
the difference between
being correlated with cancer
and being a way of bringing it about
is not one that can captured
by looking at only at the dynamical loss.
So if one wants to avoid getting cancer
or one has to know not simply
what cancer is correlated with
as a matter of physical
law, but what causes it,
that is what brings it about.
So this was Cartwright's observation
and it led to a lot of
hand-wringing wondering
what causal information
adds to the kind of
global dynamic laws that Russell took
as paradigmatic, the physical laws,
and philosophers played
around a little bit
with probabilistic and
counterfactual analysis.
And there were a lot
of unresolved questions
about the metaphysics of causal relations.
One strand in contemporary discussion,
followed Russel in denying
that physics has any real place
for causation and continued
to reject causal talk
as anything but folk physics.
Now in the last 15 years or so.
However, there's been a real revolution
in our understanding of causal thinking
stemming from a lot ally developments
in a coalition of fields
from computer science to psychology.
And it was really the structural
causal modeling framework
from Pearl and sort of
parallel development
since Beartooth be more in shyness.
And its philosophical
development by Jim Woodward
that transformed the discussion.
So what the framework does
is it gives us a precise, formal framework
for representing causal relationships.
That's well-suited to causal
search and discovery in science
has been at the center of
developments in causal learning
and statistical inference.
It can be used to define
normative solutions,
to causal inference and judgment problems.
It's facilitated new insights
into rural causal thinking cognition,
the influence and the power of
that framework are undisputed
and largely due to its utility
in raising concrete scientific questions.
That can be investigated in laboratory.
From a philosophical point of view,
what it's done is helped
us resolve I think,
the puzzle brought out by the exchange
between Russell and Cartwright.
That is the disappearance of
causes from the fundamental
level of a physical
description on the one hand
and their indispensability
and practical reasoning
on the other.
And the way that it resolves the puzzle
is by giving us an
articulated understanding
of where and how causation
or better causal thinking
and the structures that
support causal thinking
arise in the architecture of the cosmos.
And in the way that is characteristic
of philosophical questions once they pass
into the hands of the sciences
is transformed some of the old questions
while also raising new ones.
So just to highlight a
few relevant features
of the formalism.
So type causation is basic.
That is causation between types of events
and it's relative to networks.
So type causation relates types of events
like the striking of a
match of a specified kind
under given circumstances
rather than the particular striking
of a particular match at a
particular time and place.
And this accords well with science,
'cause with practice in science,
because scientists to a large part
devoted to the identification
of type causal relationships
networks are defined by
collections of variables,
individual properties are
represented by the values
of variables,
the choice of which variables to include
and which to leave out of a network
when studying a causal claim,
make a difference to whether
there is a causal link
between the pair of variables
and what the link is.
Singular causal claims.
So like the claim that a
dot on a photographic plate
was caused by the impact of an electron.
Those derived from type causation.
DAGs this is just again,
introducing relevant
features in the formalism
DAGs directed acyclic graphs
are used to represent causal relations
among variables and network.
So direct causation is
represented by an arrow,
and it's the most basic
causal relation in a network.
A variable Xi for example,
is a direct cause of another variable Xj
relative to a set of variables V,
just in case there is an
intervention on the first
that will change the value of the second
or change your probability distribution
over values of the second.
When all of the variables
in the networking question,
except those two are held fixed.
So DAGs these diagrams
give us a conspicuous way of displaying
causal relationships.
An example like this,
you can see immediately how intervening
on one variable will affect
other variables in the network.
Now, from the point of
view of this framework,
causal judgements in everyday contexts
rely on loose and tacit assumptions
about which variables
are being considered.
What's being held fixed in situ
for the purposes of assessing
the effects of one variable on another.
Those choices are made
explicit in the formalization.
And because it makes them explicit,
it lets us separate the objective
content of causal claims
from the sort of loose context,
dependent, pragmatic factors
that guide the choice of the network.
So the question that comes out of
the Russell Cartwright exchange
was how does causal information
recall go beyond the information
captured in dynamical loss
that is, what does causal
information add to those laws?
Or if it add anything,
what information contained in those laws
doesn't make it explicit?
So here's the way to think
of it, global dynamic laws,
the kinds of laws that
Newton's theory gave us.
Give us information about
the relationships between
global states at different times.
Causal information, is
information about the results
of the hypothetical interventions,
where by that we mean, questions
about what would happen.
If a variable were separated
from its earlier history
and allowed to vary freely.
Now the difficulty of with
extracting causal information
from global dynamic laws,
is that the global dynamic laws
don't allow the separation of variable
from its own past causes.
So here's an example.
Suppose someone presents you
with something like this.
The schematized model
of an engine for a car.
Has a collection of components,
a piston, an engine block, a timing chain,
a crank shaft, and so on.
Now the parts move,
but so long as they're assembled
in the form of an engine,
they have a restricted range of motion
relative to one another.
So if we modeled the engine,
remodeled the engine at
the level of description
that treats these functional
components as basic parts,
we can come up with dynamical equations,
that would describe how the
global state of the engine
varies over time.
And those dynamical
equations for the engine
would tell you that there's
a fixed relationship
with for example, the
pistons and the valve.
So given the equations,
you could use the position
of one of those things
to calculate the position of the other.
So maybe when one is up the other's down,
when the other is down,
the other one is up,
they move, but they move together.
And if you just look at the equations,
there would be three causal
hypotheses that you might
come up with.
One is that the position of
A causes the position of B,
that the position of B
causes the position of A,
or that they have a common cause.
Now remember the global
dynamical equations
just fixed the relative values of A and B.
These three hypotheses, however,
have different modal implications.
So if A causes B,
then if you kept everything
else fixed and you reached in
and you moved A up and down,
you should be able to see B move as well.
So that's what you would be committed to,
if you asserted that A causes B.
If B causes A, then the other thing holds,
you should be able to reach in
and move B keeping everything
else fixed and A should move.
If the two have a common cause
then neither of these
interventions should affect
the value of the other,
since the common cause C
would be left unaffected,
and it's the thing that causes both.
Now, in the case of an open
system, like a car engine
intervention from the outside
are physically realizable
and often in a way that
serves to effectively separate
the variable from its own past causes
inside the system of interest.
I'll say a little bit
more about this below,
but what the example here does
is it makes a logical point
that the dynamical equations
for the engine as a whole,
don't tell you which of
these hypotheses are correct,
because the counterfactuals that you need
to discriminate between these hypotheses,
between the three causal hypotheses here,
namely, what would happen
if we could hold everything else fixed
and intervene from the
outside to alter the variable
of one of the values in the network.
Those counterfactuals are
physically impossible.
There is no model of the engine as a whole
compatible with this global dynamic laws,
in which the antecedents
of those counterfactuals
is realized.
So if the engine comprised
the universe as a whole
and the global equations
were all that we had,
then there would be no way of discerning
the underlying causal
structure of the engine,
just by looking at the dynamical laws.
The reason that, that is,
is not that the information
that we can extract
from global laws,
it's not that laws don't
have modal content,
is that the modal content
that they have is global.
So global laws will tell
us what kinds of worlds
are possible, but they don't
tell us what would happen
if we could intervene
on one of those worlds
in a way that's contrary to law.
So in logical terms,
we would say the antecedents
to intervention counterfactuals
are normal logically impossible.
That is they're contrary to law.
So if we take the global
laws is more basic,
we don't generally get causal information.
So that tells us something about
in terms of the content of causal claims,
what distinguishes them
from what we can get out
of global dynamical laws.
But it gives rise to another question.
And the question is,
how is causal knowledge
possible at our world?
If causal information is
information about what would happen
if some variable were
separated from its past causes
and allowed to vary freely.
And in fact,
no variable is ever actually
separated from its past causes.
How could we study causal structure?
And the answer is that in practical terms,
there are various ways
effectively randomizing
the values of the variable,
which provides a separation
and effective separation
from its own past causes so
that we can treat changes
to the values of that
variable as interventions.
So for example, flip a coin,
have a random number
generator set the value for
the variable you want to intervene on,
let a lab assistant choose one at-will.
Any variable that can be manipulated
and whose own causes are uncorrelated
with the variables of interest.
That is the variables on which
the causal impact of the variable
that you're intervening on
is the one that you're interested in
can be regarded for such purposes
as external to the system
and changes in the value of such variables
can be regarded as interventions.
This of course is the essence
of scientific experimentation,
the possibility of knowledge
of causal knowledge
rests on the fact that we can effectively
isolate systems in the laboratory,
manipulate the external input to them
and observe the impacts
of our manipulations.
And this in its turn tells
us something important
about how we should think of
the metaphysics of causation
or better I would say.
the physical substructure
that supports causal belief.
And it's this in a world that
is as complicated as ours
and which decomposes
into a collection of
rule govern components,
where the laws governing configurations
can be given in terms of
laws governing components
and their interactions.
Causal information can be extracted
from laws governing components
and the interactions.
One can concoct very
simple examples, sorry,
a very simple world.
A worlds in which there are
a normal logical restrictions
that is law like restrictions
on initial conditions
in which causal information
cannot be extracted
from the global laws.
But what's really going on
is that in those worlds,
the global dynamic laws will
not allow us to recover laws,
governing components and interactions.
So long as one is willing to
take the local non-biological
structure of the world, that as basic,
one can ground facts about
the results of hypothetical
interventions in that structure,
that is to say in the laws
that govern the components,
deriving the global laws from restrictions
on configurations of components.
And indeed that that follows
the standard practice in physics.
So when you learn Newtonian
physics, for example,
you learn that an object
will not change its motion
unless a force acts on it.
That the force on an object
is equal to it's mass
times acceleration, and that
went to objects interact,
they exert forces on one
another equal magnitude
and opposite direction.
So what you learn,
is really the laws
governing the components.
You piece together an understanding
of the equations of motion
for the universe as a whole,
from an understanding
of what its parts are
and the laws that govern the components.
So I think it's a sort of
perversion of the content
of physical theories to make
a lunch for the global laws,
and then insist that the full
modal content of the theory
has to be somehow extractable
from the form that they take
for our world,
for the particular
configurations of components
that makes up our world.
Now, the relations captured in DAGs
there's intervention
is causal relationships
are experimentally accessible.
They're often first in
the order of discovery,
they're part of the surface
fabric of the world,
and almost tailor fit to play the role
that Cartwright
highlighted when she argued
for the indispensability
of causal relations
in practical reasoning.
But there's another tradition
that comes out of the later Russel
in this case, by way of the philosophers
Reichenbach, and Nathan,
sorry, Wesley Salmon.
And that receives its fullest development
in Phil Dowe's work.
And this tradition
analyzes causal relations
in terms of what he
calls causal processes.
So causal processes are chains of events
that are related by interactions
where a causal interaction
is an interaction between
events or objects that
involves the local exchange
of a conserved quantity.
Causal processes can be defined
more directly in terms of
micro dynamical loss.
So cause the process.
So this is a way of trying
to introduce a causal notion
that one could connect more directly
to the sorts of dynamic laws
that are given by Newtonian physics.
Causal process and
interventionists accounts
are sometimes treated as
competing accounts of causation,
but we don't need to choose between them.
They're both useful.
And in classical physics we
find interpretations or examples
of both interventionists,
causal relationships and causal processes.
In the Dowe tradition.
We have causal processes
at the fundamental level,
and we have the kind of
manipulable causal relationships
captured by DAGs all over the place.
These relationships are
undiscriminating about levels.
They're neutral about
underlying processes.
They represent often
local scaffolded relations
among variables
that can be investigated experimentally
frequently without knowledge
of the underlying processes.
Both moreover, that is both
the relationships captured
by DAGs and causal processes.
Both of those notions capture some aspects
of our everyday notion of cause
the interventionists relate notion
captures the idea that you
have a causal connection.
When one thing can be used
to bring about another.
Causal processes on the other hand
capture the idea that influences
propagate through space
causal influences propagate through space
and that they satisfy the expectation
that causal connections should
be mediated by mechanisms
and that they involve
some sort of contact,
some sort of local bumping
up against one another.
So if intervention is causal relationships
are part of the surface
fabric of the world.
Then you can think of causal processes
as part of the deep theoretically
postulated substructure
that supports the high level
relationships captured by DAGs.
So I said that causal physics
gives us both causal processes
and the high level causal
networks captured by DAGs.
But there's a puzzle
about the relationship
between the sort of high
level causal pathways
and the underlying dynamical processes,
that's crucial to
understanding causal notions
of both kinds.
So interventionists causal relationships
of the kind captured in DAGs
have one striking feature
they're temporarily asymmetric.
So they run in one direction,
from past to future.
And that temporarily symmetry
is no mere matter of convention.
If we follow Cartwright in saying
that was definitive of
causal relationships,
as distinct from mere
probabilistic correlations,
is that they can function
as strategic groups
to bringing about ends.
Then it's manifest and
pervasive empirical fact
about our world
that all known strategic
routes to bring about ends
run from past to future.
- [Priya] So Jenann if I may interrupt
to have a quick question.
So in the absence of micro physical laws,
does it mean that causation
is not well-defined
or it cannot be established?
So I'm thinking of something like gravity.
So you do not have micro physical laws.
So I'm curious is that
in the previous slide
you had that as one of the points.
- So that's true of causal processes.
- [Priya] I see.
- So you're right quantum mechanics,
there's no mechanism for the
propagation of gravitation
and that's right.
So according to causal process account,
there's no causal link between sort of
there's no causal
mechanism or causal process
by which gravitational
influence is propagating.
- [Priya] Thank you for that.
- Sure.
It's a good question. Thank you for that.
So, let me go back to, okay.
So as I'm saying that
the temporally symmetric,
is no matter of convention
and indeed of all of the
reasons that Russel gave
in that early paper for
saying that causation
had been purged from physics
at the fundamental level,
this is the one that
persuaded most people.
The underlying dynamic laws
are simply equations of motion
that relate the state of
the universe at one time
to say that the others,
they have no intrinsic
direction of determination.
So they couldn't in that sense
be properly called causes.
So now this gives rise
to a straight forward
physical puzzle however,
how do the kinds of high
level causal pathways
that have set an objective
part of the surface fabric
of our world arise from
temporally symmetric
underlying laws.
Now this isn't the kind of question
that people in the lab studying
signal pathways and cells,
and so on typically ask.
Scientists who empirically
investigate the causal structure,
who, sorry, who impaired the
investigate causal structure
of particular kinds of systems
take it for granted that
causal relations run
from past to future.
So they set up experiments
that allow localized interventions
and they look for the
temporarily downstream effects.
But it is a theoretical
question for the physicist
trying to relate the
kinds of causal pathways
cited in for example, biology
labs to an underlying theory.
And as it happens,
it's a question that's been
illuminated by research
into the foundations of thermodynamics.
So for those of you who
don't know the history
that research began in mid 19th century,
and it was originally
focused on trying to derive
the phenomenological asymmetries
embodied in the second
law of thermodynamics
from time symmetric laws
of classical mechanics.
And it turned only quite recently
into a very general account
of the sources of temporal
asymmetry in our world.
So a conversation that
started by being about why,
for example, a gas will disperse
to fill an open container,
but not collect
spontaneously in one corner
or why ice melts when placed
in a warm glass of water.
But we don't see ice
cube spontaneously form
out of warm water without
a change in temperature.
How that turned into a conversation
about why, for example,
we remember the past, but not the future
and why time seems to
flow from past to future,
and why causation doesn't run backwards.
And as in the revolution in
our thinking about causation
that I said, came with the development
of the structural causal
modeling framework.
There was input from both
scientists and philosophers
that was sort of instrumental
to the development.
So for example,
there was Boltzmann and Maxwell
and Gibbs, all scientists,
but there was also Reichenbach,
David Albert, Huw Price,
all of course philosophers.
So there remains a lot of
dispute in the foundations
of thermodynamics in
dispute in particular,
about how to understand
some of the most important
philosophically important
temporal asymmetries.
But it was really David Albert's account
from this book in 2000 that
brought the foundations
of thermodynamics into the
kind of conceptual focus
that made it possible to
really attack these questions.
So Albert's account
that is philosophically
interesting temporal asymmetries.
So Albert's account has
three first principles,
there is the Newtonian laws of motion.
There's a Statistical Postulate,
and there's something that
he calls the Past-Hypothesis.
So here's how it works.
Newtonian laws of motion,
are just the familiar time symmetric laws
that Russell was referring to.
This Statistical Postulate
is a probability distribution
that assigns probability distribution
to assist them being
in a given microstate,
given its macrostate.
Macrostate is just given by the values
of thermodynamic parameters.
The Statistical Postulate is
strict addition to the law,
so it doesn't follow from them directly,
but there are a lot of attempts
to motivate it dynamically.
The Past-Hypothesis, the
third of these postulate,
is a contingent hypothesis
about the early history of the world.
It says that the universe started
in a state of low enough entropy,
to make thermodynamic generalizations
applicable for the
roughly 15 billion years,
that we think that those
generalizations have held.
And here's how the account goes.
The three postulates
work together as follows.
Newtonian dynamical laws
do limit the space of
physically possible worlds.
The Past-Hypothesis knocks
out all of those worlds
that don't start out
in a low entropy state.
And then if you take
the initial microstates
of the remaining worlds,
and you apply the
Newtonian dynamical laws,
you will see that some
of those remaining worlds
will be on what are called
entropy increasing projectories.
That is to say that their
entropy will be increasing
from that initial state over its history,
until it reaches equilibrium.
And some of them will be on
entropy decreasing trajectories.
That is where the entropy will decrease
from the initial state.
As far as the dynamical laws go,
there will be worlds of both
kinds in the remaining set,
the statistical postulate,
then we'll enter in
and provide a probability
distribution over the worlds,
that overwhelmingly favors those
on entropy increasing trajectory.
So the result of these three things
is that the most probable and
not just the most probable,
but the overwhelmingly most
probable history of the universe
is one where in entropy rises.
Now, Albert himself gives the
account at the global level
where I mean,
he presents it in exactly
the way that I just said,
that you have a probability
distribution over worlds
and you apply the whole
account at the level of worlds
as a whole.
One need not do that.
Formally it works just as well
for some local adiabatically
isolated subsystem of the world.
That is a system that's
not exchanging energy
with its environment.
And indeed, there are
good reasons for thinking
that the story might best
be told at that level.
Why?
Because those are the systems
to which thermodynamics
is typically applied.
And second is not obvious
whether the local story follows
from the global one.
I think it does, but it's not,
it's not as perspicuous as if
you give the story directly
at the local level.
And finally, the probabilities
have a much clearer
interpretation if the story
is told at the local level.
So if you look at Albert's postulates,
the Newtonian laws are times symmetric.
There is no direction of
determination built in to them.
And the Statistical Postulate,
is also time independent.
So the only time asymmetric assumption
is the Past-Hypothesis.
You know that the initial
state of the world
was low entropy,
but there's no corresponding
boundary condition
in the future.
And it's a particularly
crucial part of the story
because it's doing all
of the explanatory work
in terms of deriving the
temporarily symmetries.
There's been some important
discussion about the right form
for that hypothesis.
Everybody agrees that some
kind of temporal asymmetry
in boundary conditions needs to be assumed
to extract a temporal
asymmetries of thermodynamics.
In Albert's account is low entropy state
for the universe that
sometime it's this and past.
Mathias Frisch, in a discussion
of the asymmetries embodied
in causal reasoning,
has shown that there are
different ways of expressing
the time asymmetric assumptions,
that are needed to generate
the sorts of asymmetries
that would support causal inferences.
So he points out that it would
do just as well, for example,
to assume a Causal Markov Condition,
that is that any node in a dag
is conditionally independent
of its non-descendants given its parents,
or as an assumption about
microscopic randomness
in the initial, but not
final state of the system.
I think there's no substantive question
about which of these
assumptions is more fundamental.
You can derive them from one another.
There are different ways of
describing the structures,
that is to say the contingent
asymmetries in our world
that support causal inferences
running from past to future.
Others have pointed out that
in the explanatory story
what's really needed to generate
thermodynamic generalizations
is not really an initial low entropy,
but the randomness or
uniformity the early universe
that matters.
So while there's a lot sort
of to sort it out here,
what there is broad agreement
that pending the mathematical conjectures
on which this account rests,
the local macroscopic asymmetries
in our part of the universe,
have their origin in a fact
about the state of our universe
in the distant past,
that developed under
effective the classical laws
into a world with the sorts of emergent
macroscopic asymmetries
captured in thermodynamic generalizations.
Now, if one is interested
in how this story connects
specifically to causal inference,
one will be interested in
some different ways of
stating the assumptions
that are needed to derive the asymmetries.
If one's more interested
in Cartwright's idea,
that if you're given a
body of correlations,
the causal pathways are
the ones that can be used
as strategic groups to bring about ends.
Here's how to get that
in a way that connects
more naturally to that idea.
So this is a conception of causation
that brings the connection
to agency into the foreground
and connects to people's
pre theoretic idea,
that causation is
something that you can use
to bring about ends.
If we start in a world with
the thermodynamic gradient
and we hold fixed all of
the information embodied
in the present surveyable
macroscopic state of the world.
So the kind of information
that an agent has
just by looking around.
And here, I don't mean just what you get
by looking around you
and holding fix the ambient temperature
and dispositions of
medium-sized dry goods.
I mean, you hold fixed all
of the information embodied
in libraries, scientific databases,
all of the information
that we've somehow amassed
and recorded, or that we could
have accessed and recorded.
And we ask what's the
probabilistic effect,
holding all of that fix,
of local interventions
on the present state of the environment
of a kind that are
possible in practical terms
for agents like us?
So you manipulate some feature
of your local environment
and you apply the probability postulate
to obtain the probability distribution
over the possible microstate of the world.
And then you evolve that
forward or backward in time
using the classical mechanical laws.
Here's what happened,
if you just evolving
it forward or backward
with the classical micro mechanical laws,
you can't really predict much
about either the past or the future.
Why?
Because there are lots of different ways
that the world could be.
Everything depends on
the actual microstate
of the universe, and you
don't need to just know
what's going on locally
microscopically here,
you need to know what's
going on everywhere.
You need the micro state
of the universe as a whole
to predict anything
with the classical laws.
If however we conditionalize
on low entropy state
in the distant past,
then the probabilities of past events
of which we have any kind
of macroscopic record
will be unaltered,
but the intervention will
raise the probability
of certain kinds of
macroscopic featured in this.
Now the backward part of this,
that is the question of what
makes something a record.
And the reason that condition
lies under low entropy past
makes the macroscopic
present full of records.
That's something that's
been extensively studied.
So if you went to Carlo
Rovelli's talk, for example,
the first in the series that I mentioned,
he did a beautiful job of making explicit
the physics of that.
But the way to think of it
and the way that one has to think of,
there's a little bit more
that needs to be added here,
which is that one has to
think of the internal,
one has to think in a
certain way of the internal
dynamics of the agent.
What I'm trying to show you
is how all of these pieces
fit together conceptually
at the macro scale,
to help us understand causation.
And the way to think of it,
to get the causal stuff into it,
is that the causal asymmetry
is really the flip side
of the asymmetry of records.
So when you intervene in
the local environment,
there will be traces in the
future of your intervention.
What you'll be doing is
you'll be doing some work.
You jump into a swimming pool,
you leave a footprint in the sand,
you dig a ditch or you build a house.
And what you're doing from
a physical perspective
is you're creating an ordered
state of the environment
that will take some time to decay.
So what you think of as
the effects of your actions
are the future record of its occurrence.
That means if we look
for the strategic routes
for bringing about ends.
If we look for ways of
doing something in the here
and now that will make a
difference to probabilities
of future events,
of probabilities of events
at other times and places,
we will find that there's
nothing that one can do
to make a difference to the past,
but there's a lot that we
can do to make a difference
to the future.
So the causal asymmetry,
is just the flip side of
the asymmetry of records.
What you're doing when you
act in the here and now
is you're creating future
records of your present action.
Now so far, everything that I've said
stays at the level of physical structure.
We've talked about the
temporarily symmetric laws,
about the asymmetric intervention pathways
that can be studied in the
lab and captured in dyads.
We have the external
infrastructure in place
that just grabs the macroscopic
fabric of the world.
Now we're in a position to
talk about causal concepts.
So we've moved from talking
about structure in the world
that is external infrastructure
in the environment,
to talking about something
that has a role in an agent's
internal cognitive economy.
To do that, we need to introduce an agent.
And we couple the agent to
the macroscopic structure
of the world.
What is an agent?
An agent is the system
whose job it is to extract
information from the environment
and use it to guide behavior.
Is coupled to the world via
sensory and motor pathways
that give it macroscopic information
and sensory feedback on
its own interventions.
And so now we ask how do
causal concepts arise?
Which is to say, we look at the role
that those concepts play in an
internal influential network.
That's linked to perception at one end
and to action at another.
So an agent that is an agent like this,
that's coupled to the environment
by sensors and actuators,
and it's giving macroscopic information,
will be interested in
knowing how, what it does
affects what it sees in causal concepts
will be defined both by their
connections to perception
and to action.
And the sciences that
are relevant to studying
causal concepts, now
looking not at the world,
but looking at the agent
and the way that her
causal concepts are nested
in her internal economy,
the sciences that are
relevant to study that,
are psychology cognitive science.
And there's just a wealth
of fascinating work
on causal cognition and learning
on the development of causal ideas
on their role in inference, deficient,
and action in world judgment.
So if we step back and we
take a kind of cross section
of the world ordered by scale,
and we look at the layers of structure
from the microscopic all the
way up to the macroscopic,
up to the level of the human being,
interacting with the
macroscopic environment,
the picture that sort of coming into focus
looks something like this,
the bottom layer, there's
the geometry of space time,
which in a classical
setting imposes or embodies
constraints on the causal
connectability view events.
And by that,
I mean their connectability
by causal processes.
There's the matter content.
And there's the temporarily
symmetric microscopic laws
that tell us how the matter
in one volume of space-time
affects matter in other
volume of space-time.
Or how the state of the world at one time
relates to a state at another.
And then there's the emergent
macroscopic asymmetries.
And the macroscopic asymmetries arise.
You remember because of the
low entropy boundary condition
at one end of the universe.
The macroscopic asymmetries in their turn,
support the emergence of
features that use information
to guide behavior
because of the way that
the macroscopic asymmetries
allow the present state of
the world to contain records.
Information makes the macroscopic states
rich with information that agents can use.
Eventually those agents get complex enough
that they do something that we
would recognize as thinking,
and by the time we get
to creatures like us
thinking is causal from stem to stern.
Now, while there's not much that's known
and various points of dispute,
the sketch that I just gave,
it is robust with respect to
most of the emerging details.
And notice how much it transforms
both our understanding of causation
and our understanding of ourselves
is very different from anything
that might've come out
of simply reflection
on the concept of cause.
No single part of this story
is the story of what causes are.
But I think that once all
of the pieces are assembled,
there's no further question,
no story about the
metaphysics of causation
that needs to be answered.
There are two questions
that philosophers always
want to ask about causes.
They wanna ask are causes
inside or outside the head?
Are they part of the mind
independent fabric of reality,
or are they in the eye of the observer?
And they want to ask,
where does the asymmetry come from?
To take the second one first,
we've just seen a rather complex answer
to the source of the asymmetry.
What we saw was that there's
not a single asymmetry,
but rather a couple of
related asymmetries.
There's the thermodynamic gradient
created by low entropy
state of the universe,
which creates a macroscopic asymmetry
that in its turn supports the emergence
of information gathering
and utilizing systems.
When such systems get sufficiently complex
information and gathering and utilization
takes the form of conceptual activity
creatures like this
develop causal concepts
with a built-in asymmetry
that reflects in asymmetry
in their practical and epistemic
relationship to the world.
So while there is no
fundamental asymmetric relation
of determination in physics
for creatures like us,
who coupled to the macroscopic
structure of the world,
the fact that information
flows from the past
and causal information
runs into the future
is a fundamental, informative
feature of our experience.
And one that frames every
aspect of our thoughtful
engagement with the world.
And when that's built
into all of our concepts.
Now on the question
of whether causes are
inside or outside the head,
the right thing to say is
partly inside and partly outside
for the reasons that I just gave.
Are pre-scientific ideas about causation,
aren't really, I think, articulated enough
to single out one part
of this layered structure
that leads from microscopic processes
all the way up to the coupled interaction
between agent environment,
in which causal thinking has its home,
as where the causes are.
Scientifically there's no uniform usage.
Physicists will speak of
space your temporal geometry
is in coding causal structure,
but when biologists talk
about causal structure,
they mean something much higher
in that stratigraphic hierarchy.
When ordinary people talk about causation,
they invoke ideas closely
associated with the phenomenology
of pushing and pulling
something with a sort of quasi
muscular notion of compulsion in mind.
We can see how all of these ideas arise
and how they relate to one another.
And I don't really see that
there's a factual question
to be settled about,
which of them captures
the essence of causation
or about which point at which
point in that hierarchy,
we finally really have causes.
Now notice that this kind
of account is different
from what we might think
of as the prototypical
philosophical analysis of a concept.
And it's characteristic of the way
in which we get a scientific account
of one of those notions
that play a central role
in mediating our practical
and epistemic interaction
with the world.
Other notions that are like this,
I think are probability and
information to some extent.
There's an external component.
That is the infrastructure
in the environment
that agents use as strategic
pathways to bring about ends.
And there's also an internal component
and the content of causal concepts
understood partly in terms of their role
in internal inferential networks.
And a big part of understanding
what causation is, is fitting
those pieces together.
It saying how agents with
the kind of information
that we have,
and our practical
capacities for intervention
in a world that is objectively
structured like ours,
how those agents develop
and use causal ideas.
So there are two
philosophically, I'm almost done.
There are two philosophically
important aspects
of the account.
One is that it secures the
objectivity of causal relations,
making apt objects for scientific study.
And the second is that
it's a really good antidote
to redefine causal relations
as compulsive asymmetric
relations between local events
built right into the
fundamental fabric of the world.
There are causal pathways
written into the fabric of the world,
but those pathways are neither
asymmetric nor compulsive.
We see, I think that that complete account
of the metaphysics of causation
is given by the facts about our world
and about our position in it
that support the acquisition
of news of causal concepts.
And that account does not
treat causal relationships
as asymmetric, pushy
relationship dependents
that are written into the
fundamental fabric of the world.
But it makes causal relations objective
in all of the ways that
should matter to science,
it makes perfect sense to think of science
as devoted to, as Russell
put it, in his later years,
discovering the causal
skeleton of the world.
So I think of this kind of
account as a side-on view,
the side-on view brings into focus,
the assemblage, the side-on view
because it takes a kind of side on look
at the agent coupled to the world
and the processes that
mediate its interaction.
Now, the sidearm view brings into focus
and assemblage of different structures,
starting with geometry,
becoming progressively more
articulated by the context
and coming into sharp relief
in their distinctive role
in practical reasoning
for situated agents.
There are a number of
well-defined precise concepts
as I said, that can be introduced
to talk about structures
at different levels
of this element.
The reasons that I gave,
I think no account of causal concepts
that doesn't bring out
their distinctive role
in practical reasoning
and the way in which causal concepts
are structured by that
rule can be complete.
But we can't talk about causal
structure in the strip down,
since that applies just at the level of
fundamental geometry.
So that's the difference
between causal structure
and causal concept.
At that level, one thinks of space time,
as in coding relations
of causal connectability,
one can talk about also causal structure
in a way that links it
to physical processes.
As in the tradition that leads from
Sam and through Phil Dowe.
One can also talk about causal structure
in a way that connects it to
the kinds of emergent pathways
captured in DAGs,
or one can talk about it in
a way that ties it to agency
with all of the
articulation and influential
and practical commitments
that come from being embedded
in a whole network of concepts.
These notions don't compete.
We shouldn't insist on a single notion
that's gonna serve all of these purposes.
Each one of them is well defined
and we can see how causal emotions
become increasingly structured.
Increasingly articulated
as the setting is enriched.
Is precisely because the notion,
I think, spans all of these levels,
from fundamental geometry
up to the agent's strategic pathways,
that it is so useful in
linking them together.
As I said, I think something similar
can be set of probability and information
is precisely the level span
and character of these notions
that makes them particularly well suited
to bridging the divide between
purely physical description
and the structured interface
that the mind brings
to its understanding of nature.
So the question of how.
(words lost in cross talk)
- [Priya] And this is really beautiful,
the side-on view really powerful.
I was just wondering,
is there any ordering preferred ordering
just like a hierarchy of ways of looking
or are these just, is
it an ordering in these?
- So there is a physical
ordering, so if one starts,
so that's why I said,
if one starts with physical
structure ordered by scale,
then at the bottom level,
there's gonna be geometry.
(words lost in cross talk)
You can characterize
geometry independently
of the matter content.
And then when you enrich
it with the matter content,
then you get like, cause
of process notions.
And then when you add a
thermodynamic gradient,
you get the asymmetry.
So there's a sort of
natural, physical ordering.
And as you add more to
the physical description
of the system,
you get increasingly enriched
notions of causation.
So that's the way that I'm picturing it.
- [Priya] So it's just
that the agents are really
what I had a sort of question about
whether these agents,
you could have some
conception of the agents,
even as you look at the connectability.
So you may have some notion of agency
which stands to be
verified and consolidated,
but I was just curious about that.
- Okay, so you're putting
your finger on something that
it would take,
I mentioned in passing and it
would take a good deal more
to sort of articulate in a convincing way.
But the way that I think about it
is that it's actually the
thermodynamic gradient
and the fact that the
makes the macroscopic
structure of the world
rich with information that
explains the emergence of agents
in evolutionary terms.
So if you think that what
agents are is by their nature,
so to speak, but they're designed to do
is be information gathering
and utilizing creatures
then in a world where there
is no thermodynamic gradient,
there's gonna be no agents.
So agents were designed and selected
because of the opportunities
for information gathering
and use that's provided by
the thermodynamic gradient,
they arise so to speak,
to take advantage of those opportunities.
And then that in its turn
explains why agents like us
our senses are coupled to the macroscopic
structure of the world.
So sometimes people, I know
we're almost out of time,
so I'll say this quickly,
and maybe we can talk about it more,
but I think what people
sometimes speak as though
when you say that really
the asymmetry rises
with the thermodynamic gradient
and it's a macroscopic course graining
imposed by the thermodynamic gradient
that gives rise to the assymetry.
They sometimes say, oh,
so it's just an artifact
of the fact that we happen to have senses
that parse the world,
that see and of course, green way.
And I think the right direction,
you know, when you see
the whole assemblage
in the way that I've sketched it,
the right way to see the
direction of explanation is
we see in macroscopic terms
because that's where the opportunities
for gathering and using information.
- Thanks, I mean, we can
continue this offline.
I get what you were at.
- Good. I'm almost done.
So I'll end quickly then.
So the general idea, and
this is just a concluding
to bring it back around.
The general idea is that the question
of how causation arises in
the structure of the cosmos
has been alive one since Russell observed
that it appears to have disappeared
from the fundamental level
of physical description.
So in 2003, Hartry Field called this,
quote, the central problem in
the metaphysics of causation.
And it's a question that's
animated with a good deal
of recent discussion in philosophy.
I transformed that question
into the question of
how causation arises,
the question of how causation arises
into the question of how causal thinking
and the structures that
support causal thinking arise,
and then assembled the pieces
of what we have learned
about causation the last 20 or 30 years
into the outline of an
answer to those questions
and suggested that once
those questions are answered,
there's no specifically
metaphysical question
about causation that remains.
So this sort of naturalists,
this is a kind of naturalistic pragmatism.
That seems to me the only sensible away,
only sensible way to approach
ontological questions,
whether it's a question of what cause are,
what causation is or what democracy is.
Thank you.
- Great, thank you so much Jenann
for this really thought provoking and
sort of exquisite explanation.
I mean, there are obviously
really deep foundational questions
and it's really sort of
testimony to your clarity
that you touched upon many of them.
So I would like to a big round of applause
and I see a lot of people
have the clap emoji on.
So at least I wanted to
give you an auditory clap.
Thank you so much.
So I think we'll open
up for questions now.
So I noticed there's a question
from Alexander (indistinct).
So he says,
I noticed that in the structure
at different levels slide
that you showed one thing
that wasn't on the list
was a statistical mechanical
probability distribution
over microstates,
this looks essential
to the Albert picture,
but you don't seem specially
wedded to this precise account.
So the question is to
what extent do you think
introducing non-dynamic chance
is essential for giving an
account of emergent causation?
- I think it's essential and
actually what the probability
postulate was meant to be
this is called mechanical
probability distribution
and is essential to the whole picture.
So sorry if that wasn't clear.
- Great. Thanks for that clarification.
And we have another
question from Peter Morgan
who is asking,
are there other orderings then scale
that we could have in
mind for a side-on view,
systematic organization for example?
- Yes, absolutely.
And that would be natural
in the biological context.
Yes. I mean, that's absolutely.
- Thanks are there any other questions?
- [Jenann] Oh great.
- So we have one from Jenny who is asking
which role has causation in
quantum mechanics for you?
- Okay, so there are two
questions you might be asking
one is whether quantum
mechanics plays any role
in this story and the answer is no.
So this whole sort of hierarchy
is sort of erected on effectively.
As I told the picture's erected on
a kind of effectively
classical level of description.
If you're asking, well, what
does one say about causation
in quantum mechanics?
Huge open question.
I think,
there are different ways
that one could answer it
depending on how one disambiguates.
The different notions of causation.
So if you're asking,
are there causal processes
in quantum mechanics?
That is, chains of interactions,
involving the exchange of
conserved quantity, the answer is
not right now, not in space time,
is the answer to that.
So if you're asking,
are there sort of interventionists notions
of causation that are
applicable in quantum mechanics?
The answer is yes.
And in fact, some people have used
interventionists notions to
argue that quantum mechanics
almost by its nature
involves retro causality.
So you take the quantum formulas
and you ask yourself what
happens if I intervene here
and you see causal relations under
certain conditions running into the past.
So big open question,
really interesting question.
And I think there's a number
of different questions
that one can ask,
but it's not one that played any role
in the story that I told.
- So we have a question,
sort of a clarification request from Paul.
So is causation structure asymmetric
at the microscopic level?
If you're saying it is not,
how could that be given
the low entropy state
that we started from?
- At the micro it
absolutely is asymmetric.
So again, you know, there were some,
I was sort of trying to
assemble the big pieces,
so I didn't go into details
of retails little ones.
And when I did it, wasn't clear
enough, but here's the idea.
So you start the,
I'm gonna use kind of the Albert accounts
though you can make twiddles
to the Albert account
if you object to the particular
form that he has of the past
hypothesis as a probability possible,
that just clear as to
say it in that setting,
here's the idea.
You assume low entropy boundary condition,
you take the presence or
the able macro structure
of the world.
And you assume a probability possibility.
And you ask what happens if I
intervene on a kind of online
environment in the kind
of way that we think of
normally when we're talking
about the sorts of manipulations
that embedded agents like us can make?
How do you answer that question
in the statistical mechanical framework?
You take the probability distribution,
you evolve at first past
to find out whether the intervention
makes a difference to the past,
and then you evolve it forward
to find out whether the intervention
makes a difference to the future.
When you evolve it backwards,
if your conditionalizing on a
low entropy state in the past,
you will get the results
that it makes no difference
to any event of which there
is a macroscopic record.
And if you think about it
for like a minute and a half,
you'll find out that includes
pretty much everything
that we could form any
sort of belief about this,
at least potentially a
macroscopic record of some kind
about whether or not the event took place.
If you do that in the forward
direction, you say again,
you take the low entropy
boundary conditioning past,
presence available
macrostate of the world,
and you ask what happens if I
intervene on the environment?
So I step in the sand, I built a house,
I dig a ditch.
And what you find when you evolve,
the probability distribution forward
is pretty much what common sense thinks of
as the effects of those
kinds of interventions
are the ones that are
assigned high probability
by the probability distribution.
So that's the way that you
get the causal asymmetry
out of the statistical mechanical account.
- So then Ken Winkler has
a question that actually,
I also had the same question, which is,
can you say a bit more about
your naturalistic pragmatism
and your inclination to dispense
with more traditional forms
of philosophical analysis,
perhaps by illustrating
how it might be applied
to one of the cases that you
mentioned as you concluded?
- This is a problem with period
talk where you say too much.
So that's a huge question,
but I'll say for example,
with information.
So wait, let me say a little bit.
The kind of naturalistic
pragmatism is not a conceptual
analysis of these notion.
So what it does is it takes
it's target of explanation.
Why would agents like us have
developed concepts like that?
What are the external structures
that support the application
of those concepts
and how do those concepts feature in
the internal economy of the agent?
So think about something like information.
This is a notion that's
been, you know, sort of,
it gets used a lot in physics
and it's one of these notions that's
contested in the way that causation is.
'Cause many people will say,
look, you're applying causal notions
to physical explanation,
but the notion, oh sorry,
the notion of information
to physical explanation,
but information isn't something
that we can define directly
in causal terms it's
intentionally laid in.
It's got all of these associations
that come from the use
of language and so on.
And what I want to say
in a case like that is,
well, just like the case of causation,
we can start at the fundamental level
of just physical description
before we have the introduction of agents
or anything like that with
notions of information that are
stripped down and that we can introduce
in those stripped down ways
that play a role in low level description,
making sure that we're not
importing associations.
And then as we add matter and we add,
you know ultimate and we add evolution,
we add biology and we
add ultimately agents.
So they're not just using
information to guide behavior,
not only, okay, wait, let me back up.
There's a crucial point.
There's a crucial step in
the case of information
that's worth pausing to dwell on.
When we're starting to talk about
systems that were evolutionarily designed,
we do get more structure
in that can give rise to,
that impose a little bit more articulation
on the notion of information.
So now we have slightly richer notion
and then we start getting systems
that are using information
in more and more sophisticated ways,
ultimately agents that
are introducing concepts
and inferences.
And again, it gets more articulated
until finally we have something
that's rich enough to be applied
to linguistic interactions.
So that's another very schematic sketch
of the kind of thing that I have in mind.
And at no point do you say,
this is what information is,
information is purely physical,
or information is purely mental
is something that plays a role
at different levels of that hierarchy.
- Great, I think Peter Morgan comment
so crudely put,
does a site-on view say
that the past hypothesis
could be true or false
is a global statement
about all length or other scales,
provided for example,
all creatures like us start
from the same direction in time
with no memory.
- So I'm gonna read the question again.
I'm not sure in the past hypothesis
could be true or false
as a global statement.
Yes, so the past hypothesis
though is a statement
about the macro state of the world.
So it says that the universe started
in some microstate that has low entropy.
That is a member of a
low entropy macrostate
when the thermodynamic
core screening is applied.
So it's by its nature
in a way it classifies
the early microstate of the world
by reference to the
thermodynamic core screening.
Does that? Okay.
- Peter does that?
Yeah, I guess he was putting
back to Carlo's Talk,
where the focus was on memory, right?
- Right.
So what I've been talking about
as the capacity of the universe
to bear information about its past state,
that's what Carlo was talking about
when he talked about memory.
So, and that depends
entirely on the low entropy
initial condition of the universe.
- Just waiting to see if there
are any further questions,
let's give people a minute.
So I don't see any pressing
questions, but anyway,
we could thank you so much Jenann.
We can wrap up today and
if there are any questions,
we can hold on to them
for our discussion session
tomorrow afternoon at
the same time, 3:00 pm
with Jim Woodward, as the
conversant and discussant
with Jenann.
So thank you so much
everyone for attending
and a special thank you to Jenann
for a wonderful, inspiring talk.
- Thank you for coming and
thank you for having me.
- Bye.